people on the internet have definitely
said that I look like the human
embodiment of the smell of Bo so looking
forward to your smelling me and
realizing that's not the case but I do
understand where you're coming from
hello GQ I'm loose Capaldi and these are
my essentials I have a very bad phobia
of smelling bad so what I'll do is I'll
carry the cellar with me and this is got
let's really automate the two essential
things that I used I use dry shampoo
everyday I have a roll-on deodorant
because I think it stays on NATO and I
have this aftershave that has ran out
that I bought at an airport
it's a Hugo Boss but I don't I don't
really know much about the G I just know
does that stop me from smelling like a
dead cat yes use it so these are my
sunglasses I take sunglasses whatever
our goal for some reason people really
enjoy bringing me glasses and fraud and
sunglasses at me on stage to the point
where no we travel with a suitcase full
of glasses because people just keep just
keep giving them and given up so these
were given to me by someone someone
throw these on stage but as we don't
know people like it gets like the gunk
or nucleic eggs and the gates at the
biggest reception if someone throws on a
pair of glasses and they land and I pack
them up and like me going to put them on
and went up with the one at the police
[ __ ] erupt
[Music]
as our notepad that I bring that brain
worth bit as important for me to be able
to express myself through various I mean
let --ax as good for my job I kind of
rate Lennox over time so as you can see
we've got a lot of stuff in here these
are some there's some relics here
that's his lyrics this is just a lot of
Lennox [ __ ] my rating is horrendous like
big this is just a steam inhaler that I
put my lips round and I suck on this
before every single sure it looks like
that like a bomb so people get
suspicious and then this is mid like
porcelain first coat you get them online
dr. Nelson's improved and heal up if
this has improved version of I'd hate to
have seen the [ __ ] the original the
original look
yeah [ __ ] MOFA look and yeah so this
is my mobile phone and as an iPhone it's
the new SX it's got that's one of the
x's and yes I use it for texting people
and falling people oh I've got [ __ ]
great app on my phone it's just fast
various spots I'm never gonna have a
girlfriend ever again this is my wallet
this is a wallet from from a little I
like that land they've called Acme
studios I've got all my essentials in
here I got this is a Gregg's Hyrule
Urquhart desk [ __ ] thing like here
gets me free [ __ ] pastries and there
you can get lots of things you like
sandwiches that's like a [ __ ] that's
like a party for your mouth I've got
other things in here just things I like
to look out over there and then Sean in
days oh and let's just go sometimes I
look like I go I wanna follow where she
goes I think about it she knows it no I
don't imagine oh well after this
[Music]
so next up we have my headphones these
particular headphones are Bose
headphones the noise counsellors I've
been listening to a lot of the Beatles
recently that's young new band from
Liverpool you're gonna really love them
as well as I've been listening to him
dawna Messel Sam fender as well it's a
brash guy who we were both nominated for
Brett's clerics Choice Award at the BRIT
Awards and he [ __ ] won it so I don't
have an neol well towards him and I
don't think of an every waking moment
I'm not better about it at all speaking
of music at it guitars with me I need
them as we got from out for a job and
anything I can I tried a couple guitar
and rate and stuff I first got up on
stage and sang when I was four and I
loved it after the state it's the most
fun I've had three puberty and Damned so
I was at lea bands like Queen and I was
in Japan like like people have first
started fading when my brother was at
his bands like Slipknot and my sister
was ever like green D and stuff back and
I just found it no matter what the music
sounded like everyone I listened to
seemed to kind of play guitar and I
thought great so if I want to be on
stage and sing in front of people
I'm gonna have to pick up a guitar
beyond that but songwriting became
quittin there's a similar thing I
thought but all these people are like
rate them great songs and so I'm gonna
have to raise songs if away play life so
next up has just grown my laptop I use
it all the time I love my I love it so
much my lap my album cover has no
background so that's my album cover and
this as my album everyone tells you
making an album is the most as so
transformative and you're gonna love it
and it's like us every such a I've
really found myself I was very stressful
and very boring making this album and
I'm not saying that the music is either
stressed while boiling the lava soldier
but making it album as a [ __ ] slog I
love wraiths in the salt
and I love arranging them but recording
for me just does my [ __ ] head so you
have to keep all your essentials and one
place and what better way to do that
then with a lovely big suitcase
this is my suitcase and it's from the
lovely people that were more know this
as a key so I have had for quite some
time and I quite like basically it's got
your usual pets it's got your locks at
the front here
always getting an order very much like
my trousers
no one's going in or out and it's like I
saw bumped and bruised but I can awaken
I always was the type of person to be
like I'm not going to buy like a
suitcase that's like metal but you have
to laughter around and stuff
but my tool manager said to me you have
always going to use two things you don't
even wear pants every day and you're
gonna use your suitcase every day and I
swung with so no are we lovely pants and
I have a lovely suitcase
[Music]
you